hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
in a previous video i presented this
problem
the following shape has three right
angles
its side lengths are four three four and
five
the question was to solve for the length
of the last side labeled x
now many people came up with the correct
answer but they used an incorrect proof
this is a channel about learning so we
actually want to show why the incorrect
proof is not valid and to do that we're
going to demonstrate it by varying the
problem just a little bit
imagine that this side length is equal
to three
now what is the length of x i thank
michael timothy for suggesting this
variation
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so first let's go over the incorrect way
to solve this problem many people
approached it as follows
imagine connecting this hypotenuse
this is a right triangle with legs of 3
and 4 so its hypotenuse will be 5.
we then draw this vertical distance and
it must be equal to three
that means we have another three four
five right triangle
we then transfer this length of five and
so the total length of this side will be
five plus four which is equal to nine
so what's wrong with this method
well the problem is that this distance
here is not actually three
and i'm going to show you why when we
draw this diagram to scale so let's fix
some of these lengths so that it's
actually accurate
so when you draw this vertical length at
a distance of 3 you'll see it actually
doesn't connect to that corner point
between 4 and 5. so you can't use that
method of three four five right
triangles
the method that i suggested is to
consider just this shape and looking at
the distance from end to end
how can we solve for that
well let's rotate this shape just to
make it a little bit easier
we'll join the horizontal distances and
then i'll put the vertical distance on
the left
we now have a right triangle where one
leg is four and the other leg is 8 so we
can solve for the hypotenuse as the
square root of 4 squared plus 8 squared
and that'll be equal to the square root
of 80.
we can then go back to our original
diagram
the distance from n to n will be the
square root of 80.
if we put this back into our original
shape we now have a right triangle where
one leg is 3 and its hypotenuse is the
square root of 80.
we then have x squared is equal to
square root of 80 squared minus 3
squared thus x squared is equal to 71.
this means x is equal to the square root
of 71
and that's the correct answer
i hope this video illustrated why the
other method was not a correct way to
solve this problem and i hope you
learned this correct way to solve the
problem
sometimes geometry problems are trickier
than they look
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you